When I first visited the Mekar Botanical Gardens,
Rafflesia Patma felt like I couldn't believe
it because people had already decided
that Rafflesia cannot live in
artificial conditions or on site conditions,
so it was a
special gift for the city of
Bogor. My name is S
Murawati. I work at the Botanical Gardens.
I grew up in Bogor in the
early 1980s. Where the whole
environment was full of gardens and
forests, I often saw what was
in the garden very interesting
[Music]
I saw travlesia in nature for the
first time, I felt
I'm really amazed because I've never seen
flowers that big, so Rafflesia is
not like other plants. In
general, Rafflesia is a parasite, but it's big, which
means it's just living like
that, so it's 100% dependent
on its host for its
water and nutritional needs, which actually means
si us life is very difficult to
follow because he lives from small
to large in his host plant
it's thought that the life cycle of
refleure goes something like this a tiny
Seed first needs to get into a damaged
section of the host plant a tetrastigma
Vine Once  Inside it extends out fleshy
strands that steal water and nutrients
large cabbage shaped buds then appear
along the host roughly 6 to 16 months
later these Bloom into monstrous red
Giants Flowers produce heat and release
the smell of rotting flash Which
attracts flies they pick up Pollen and
the hope is that they'll fly Off To
Another flower of the opposite gender to
pollinate it the flower only survives
for about a week And if pollination is
successful the female will produce fruit
containing
Seeds when species are faced with
Extinction conservationists create
captive populations that  could
[Music]
so from the beginning of my career
here I have had work to grow R
here, that's why I can't do it
because I am a plant that will be
very difficult to
conquer. The development of the silent flower population is
actually very
worrying today, especially now that
deforestation is so rampant that  Many forests in
Indonesia are
decreasing. My first experiment with
harflesesia was because I felt
hopeless. Well, because it was
difficult to get seeds, I switched
to another part. So grafting
is
connecting two parts of the roots of the
tetrastigma plant, which took 6 years.
Until finally we got
Rafflesia flowers that bloomed in the Bogor Botanical Gardens
using the grafting method. The
Patma Rafflesia flower has bloomed 17 times in the Bogor Botanical Gardens
[Music] There
is no specific protocol,
how do you put the
seeds in nature, so we just rub the
roots  or the stem, then we
plant the Rafflesia seeds there, there are also those
who make another treatment by
soaking them in a type of solution which
can speed up the stimulation of the seeds so they
grow quickly and I combined this
to do it in the
field. This was an extraordinary success
also because it was a
first for the Garden.  Raya
Bogor preserving nature is very
important because nature is where we
live, where else can we live
comfortably if the nature is full of
heat pollution and not pleasant to live in,
so that's actually what makes us
continue to be enthusiastic about keeping
this rafflesia in the Botanical Gardens
[  Music]
Bogor